good morning john it is better to have a
great wave than to be a great surfer
is an adage that i'm just going to have
to believe because
at this point in my life i'm i'm not i'm
not going to take up surprise but it is
something that rings true to me as
someone who built
a career on the backs of
i don't know how to ride waves while
riding
waves several significant waves
and the biggest one from the beginning
to me has always felt like it couldn't
get any bigger
it's always been a huge deal even when
no one else thought it was a big deal
but it was also something that i
couldn't really put my finger on and
still
can't really it's just too big to put
into one box and it also interfaces with
a lot of things that are outside of it
so as with all things it's just
complicated and labels are always a
little bit artificial there's
influencers and there's etsy shops and
there's haunted dolls
fast food reviews and instructional
woodworking videos and queer hockey
comics and drill tweets for a while i
was calling it fractured fame because
ever since the 1950s it seemed to me
that the like monolith of celebrity has
found more and more ways to break down
but i think that's just
because of a particular lens that i have
on the situation i think actually it's
it's bigger than
fame in general i think that power
concentrates and definitely wealth
concentrates and so it's interesting to
see
any mechanism that actually distributes
more
evenly making money connecting with
people influencing people and when
youtube started sharing revenue when
etsy got big when patreon happened
all of these things were pieces of a
puzzle
that allowed this thing that had been
going on for a really long time
to to take off and it has really taken
off in the last six months i think that
part of the economy is going to be a
bigger and bigger and bigger deal i also
think that
it will have a lot of inequality built
into it i also think that like millions
of people
will take half of the money and like
seven billionaires will take the other
half
and that's something that we should be
at least aware of i feel extremely
lucky to have been able to be a part of
it
uh it doesn't seem like something that
would have happened to me but also john
you and i think about it so much that it
allows
us to to like do it in a way that i'm
comfortable with and that like i feel
like is ultimately good
i think a lot of the stuff in this
economy is gonna be awful
and destructive but i think most of it
will be good i'm excited to see how it
goes
uh a little worried and as a person
who's been through it a lot already
hopefully like i want to be able to be
someone who can
help others who are going through it
understand the responsibility and the
value
and the perils and the joys of being
part of
this whatever this is john i'll see you
on tuesday because pizza misses over
which is wild because there's a bunch of
videos i wanted to make that i didn't
even make do i want pizza miss to be all
year round a little bit
a little bit do i have a lot of people
who don't want that to be the case in my
life
yes we're going to keep pizzamouse.com
open through the end of the weekend so
you can get your stuff
now or you can get it tomorrow or the
next day and then never again
and i'm hearing music now and that can
only mean one thing so i guess i have to
go do this
[Music]
you